not only one burger but two bad guys
smack pretty good oh no it's breaking
come on burger alright welcome to night
in night out the show where we compare a
home-cooked tasty recipe to a night out
at a fancy restaurant today we're going
on not one but two dates and then at the
end we're each going to pick which one
was the better date this week's episode
burgers delicious juicy Thank You
Phyllis I don't actually eat red meat so
that turns a wrench into things we're
gonna be making regular burgers but
we're also gonna be making veggie
burgers all right let's go store alright
first things first
beef that's cold that's not even gonna
fit on a yes I like your buns well thank
you yep good to go let's make these
burgers I'm gonna be making a bacon
cheddar Steph Bomb burger and I will be
making virtually the same thing but with
a portobello mushroom okay so let's make
our filling cream cheese a little bit
green onions cheese
[Music]
being very patiently waiting for some
actually I think he's waiting for bacon
[Music]
bacon time to stuff my burger
yes smack it all together tasty would be
proud tasting would be free huh now
going to bread this reddit flour oh my
god
egg another bread crap
oh yeah and now it's time to cook my
burger oh yeah
time for my diner smash we don't fry
things very early really don't like a
special occasion thanks Oh
oh I've never done anything that milky
chatters no no real nice melty cheese
let's customize it okay let's put on our
toppings and eat this bad boy what look
at that it's like it's like cheesy on
the inside burger on the outside it's a
lot of pressure
yeah ready
oh boy
I've never been bubbling here obviously
we did well with the patty situation
right and you know it's all fresh we
sliced this tomato today
that's like fried mmm outside so there's
like that added level of deliciousness I
know you love fried things I love
Fridays actually don't you think that
eating a burger is kind of sexy I mean I
mean look is
[Music]
what is it that makes this bird so good
I feel like it's all the levels of a
good button we've got good lettuce
it's like springy legitimate wings one
of the best burgers yeah
pretty strong showing from the Knighton
burger okay well finish off that burger
Ariel because we're getting more burgers
[Music]
ready yes oh yes so we look good we are
ready to get our burgers all ready to go
if I told you but these burgers are
Beverly Hills burgers we're going to be
so area when you're going out for
burgers what do you look for I'm coming
out - in and out Shake Shack something
simple but delicious when I go out to
burgers I want something like elevated
wait a hold on
you did not just fire fire I was like it
was a lot of cheese in that burger okay
we're here it is gorgeous
is our car their car hello chef how's
gun pleasure welcome ed ed hello I'm
David welcome in my name is David Cagney
and I'm the executive chef for the
pencil Beverly Hills we are five-star
five-diamond hotel it's it's lovely and
this is our first time here we're blow
to it why is the Night Out Burger going
to win because it's our Burger now I
like my burgers a little bit more on the
rare side
some people don't this whole party
the secret to this is you don't want to
bring our myosin inside of the beef
myosin is the protein that's found
inside it's a very technical term for a
sticky substance but we don't want to
push down on it we don't want to rush it
this is burgers why don't you want to
smash it down you want to push all this
juices out is always a bad idea don't
get spongy and what happens when you get
spongy the burger shrinks up a lot
that's happened to me before your
shrinkage problem oh yeah yes yes
there's only on cold days this right
here is a three year old and cheddar
this is a bottom radiating grill and
then we have a thing called a salamander
which would be a top radiating grill and
you take your burger right gently place
our on look how nice some sliced
tomatoes we go down through some pit
lettuce that is a tasty burger well I
don't actually eat red meat I'm sorry to
hear I appreciate that
everybody loves red meat I'm all about
the veggie burger so what are we doing
today we are making a vegetable burgers
because not everyone enjoys meat so we
have black beans some porn roasted of
course some quinoa and then this stuff
is the secret ingredient I won't tell
you that it's cornflour and then some of
this stuff this is what's called salt as
we wanted to season every bite when you
go through and then just the real quick
mix cast iron has amazing ability to
cook things very evenly it has this heat
distribution that goes in
inside the van
the crispy goodness crunchiness he wants
our veggie burger to have some truth to
it I think a lot of veggie burgers have
really turned into something that's just
gluttonous mass that's weird
so now that the veggie burger is done we
actually add a little bit of hoo-wee
cheese look at my sister's right
mind-blown
look at this out of left field this just
got so much better now do you an avocado
on your burger this morning I don't
think so no one bailed you want texture
you want flavor it should taste good
just because it's a vegetable burger
doesn't mean it should be bad hmm yeah
that's our whole goal here for all of
the food not just the burgers is to
really sit down and really you want what
you want to eat when you push down no
that is just flavor let's eat this
burger wonderful
so windswept my hair is just like
flowing in the wind that's how you dig
into this juicy burger I'm ready
[Music]
yeah savor it for a minute just savor it
it is just so juicy and the lettuce is
so crisp and refreshing why did I smash
it
why I'd smashed all my juices away but
now you know I get my times
[Music]
yeah this is a surprisingly juicy meat
with protruding everything is staying
together really well it all turns into
this like this one beautiful bite yeah
and that cheese that she's really the
only thing I'm missing is my swimsuit
I'm not pepper yeah I don't know how
we're gonna choose we have to choose a
winner are we going knighted are we
going night out which one was the better
date the burger at the peninsula was so
juicy like the juiciest ever yeah but
then also the burger at home at the time
was the juiciest burger ever
and yeah jeez I still can't get over
have mind-blowing ly good the burger was
a finish line it was but anything would
have been good there and you know I was
almost like she'd be eating her here
here like a lobster bisque
yeah like crab caveat
okay let's each say our winner on three
one two three nine nine ten
oh man oh wow
why like burgers are such a wholly
comfortable thing eating it in basically
in my sweatpants was just the way I want
to eat a burger thanks for watching
night in that out guys comment below
which you would prefer the night in or
the night out and we'll also be posting
our recipes if you try any of them be
sure to post some photos thank you all
so much for watching and we'll see you
next week I think that police Cowboys
are kind of fun it's like two fantasies
in one policeman policeman cowboy no he
is like he also fights fires
police Cowboys flash strippers oh yeah
all of those things are strippers
oh oh yes